je m'appelle ruth halimi j'ai trois
enfants est un jour d'hiver il faisait
de plus en plus froid et ma vie a
basculé deux coups relevée comme on
commence à le combat qu'est ce qui s'est
passé exactement j'étais là il m'a
appelé il m'a demandé de regarder la
fille qui sortait de sa boutique là
d'autres copines me va c'est elle qui a
entraîné votre fils 20 janvier à 21h53
ilan reçoit un coup de fil de la partie
main et après on a plus aucun signal qui
aurait pu croire qu'une chose pareille
pourrait arriver à paris en 2006 et
pourtant tout est vrai bien trouverait à
l'eau en tout 450 et on les voit tout de
suite la belle vient d'afrique quoi ce
bordel je veux par l'one qui fait il
faut trouver l'argent ça fout il faut
pas tomber dans ce piège là
si seulement pour faire peur peut pas
juste leur donner ce qu'ils mangent
non madame en france on ne paye pas ses
principes sinon on aurait désormais
vivement tous les jours qu'on produit à
l'eau ok c'est bon je laisse ça à 0,6
depuis paris là bas personne quoi il a
jamais été trop fort non même si verre
opaque par tous bords d'allier à chaque
fois tout moment de raccrocher tu
raccroches et à chaque fois c'est ilan
qui souffre un peu plus je sais ça je
pense qu'il faut non ils savent pas ce
qu'ils sont a écrit un juif a été
enlevée n'y a pas écrit un homme a été
enlevé et vont me tuer fausse assurent
qu'ils ont tués il faut les croire faire
tout ce qu'ils disent tétouan le but et
vous avez compris pourquoi vous avez
peur de la vérité
s'il vous plaît la maman s'il te plaît